look at this dress blank matching with
your mic oh well let's talk about your
dress oh hi 3d printing yes
Iris van Herpen she's amazing I think
it's so perfect for tonight I mean why
not barony um
this role may be your biggest acting
undertaking yet why this project why not
I mean I think I was waiting for
something to really like sink my teeth
into I've done a few projects again with
the CGI fantasy worlds six months you
know those kind of long undertakings but
this was a whole nother ballgame it's
talking about something which I think
needs to be social commentary is so
important right now talking about
refugees and immigration I think is so
incredibly important but also it's a
love story it's a crime thriller the
character is I'm sorry the coolest
character in the world like I spy to be
her every day so there was nothing that
no question I know you in Prague that's
minus 10 degrees centigrade which I know
you don't know but still it's freezing I
know you did a bunch of your own son the
own stunts what's scarier the flying
stunts things like that or what we just
saw you put on Instagram a naked Marie
Claire cover what's more difficulty you
know what neither the emotional stuff in
the show was the most hard I want to see
the physical part myself injuries
whatever emotionally this was the
hardest thing it was really because
there would be in a day you'd be like
attacking someone for being like out of
justice and then also breaking down
about girls who think it was such a jump
of emotions I felt like a sociopath how
did you prepare it did actually help you
run lines at all um no I was very much
alone in Prague which kind of helped
helped it helped in this sadness of the
role was she able to support you from
afar in the sadness in know her Linda
she later supported me
you know you have been such a supporter
of women and I have to ask you you came
out and you defended Taylor and she's
now said she's recording her songs which
is amazing how proud are you I mean
because I still had a lot long ago just
talking to her she never she's one of
those women who I could basically base
my character on it's just relentless
endless fire and and doesn't ever it's
not biting to draw blood it's a bit
biting when you need to bite when you
need to stand up feels up and not when
you're a woman and emotional and crazy
is when you're just defending yourself
and being who you are and that and
that's what I love about her and that's
what I will always respect about her
innate strength and just wisdom really
and a lot now she's just getting not
getting her own back because it's not a
war at the end of the day but it's like
do what's right for you if it's if
you're an artist and you make things
it's yours at the end of the day own it
and we're all so excited for what she's
done I mean have you gotten to hear the
album at all let me ask you about
another amazing if you gotta ask you
about working with Orlando I mean what a
force and how close did you guys get
during all this I mean we've been close
for a long time we've been friends I say
this to people I like went from London
where actors if we just know each other
yeah cuz we've been around for around
the block know we've been around the
same kind of social circles and it was
just really fun - what was someone I
know but then also to find that
professionist and Emmitt in him which
obviously he is because he's an
incredible actor but just to see his
passion for the project which I also had
and just to meet that
and just like fool in love with this
project and really just go for it I mean
it was such a collaborative process I'm
really he's brilliant last question how
proud are you showing this project to
your family your friends the important
people in your life and what are their
reactions I don't know I'm terrified I
haven't I mad this is the most scared
I've ever been so she's got to be
cheering you on yeah I'm sure yeah
[Music]